why is the government doing this with
the booster program well it comes down
to three pieces of data i want to show
you in the first is about waning
immunity so the chances you have of
potentially catching the disease even
after you've been double vaccinated and
we know that vaccine effectiveness the
higher these lines are the less that
chance is so the more protection you
have vaccine effectiveness is pretty
high initially 92 for pfizer that's the
dark blue dot and then astrazeneca 62.7
that's in week one but look what happens
as we go forward from week one to week
20 those lines go down and you can see
that by week 20 week 20 plus you're
talking about down from 92 percent eff
vaccine effectiveness to 69.7 percent uh
astrazeneca down from 62.7 to 47.3 so
that's a picture of waning immunity this
is against transmitting uh the disease
the second reason uh that we're talking
about boosters at the moment is that we
have some early evidence in and it
suggests the program thus far has been
really very successful these lines here
showing you just how many people in this
the latest kind of data pool have been
getting covered 19. so amongst the
unvaccinated that's the percentage uh
the highest then astrazeneca that uh
light blue bar and then fizer the higher
they are the more covert we're talking
about and look at what happens after
that booster uh program you can see
those bars going down so you're seeing
the chances of getting cover going down
that's immediately after getting the
jabs and then look after two weeks your
immunity is up those bars are down
because your chances of getting covered
are a lot lower and if you look at the
comparison between that red bar there
and those other bars you're talking
there's a kind of equation you can work
out to get vaccine effectiveness 93 94
uh it's really high and if we just plug
that into the chart we showed you just a
moment ago look look at what happens to
these lines going up it was waning and
now it's going up and not only is it
kind of back to where it started it's
actually better than where it started
for fires a little bit better and for
astrozenica a lot higher than it was
when it started this is against
transmission i should say of the disease
we know that in preventing
hospitalizations and deaths they're
really effective kind of whatever the
situation here final bit of evidence the
government has been focusing on is the
epidemiological picture across europe
basically how much covert there is and
not long ago this red line the uk was a
cause for concern now there are some
question marks over whether the uk
really was the worst in europe but
nonetheless since then the uk's line has
been more or less flat and look other
countries around the world austria uh
belgium the netherlands have risen far
faster than the uk and the concern is
that too could spread to this country
soon